NO ONE IN THE REPUBLICAN
DELEGATION SUFFERED MAJOR INJURY
ALTHOUGH SOME REPORTED BUMPS,
BRUISES, SORE JOINTS.
AT LEAST ONE CONCUSSION.
YOU CAN EXPECT MORE ARRESTS OF
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS OF FEDERAL
STATE AND LOCAL COURTHOUSES.
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES ARE
MAKING OFFICIAL A POLICY THAT
HAS DRAWN WIDESPREAD CRITICISM
FROM PRO-IMMIGRATION ADVOCATES.
WILLIAM LA JEUNESSE LOOKS AT
BOTH SIDES.
>> FOREVER CRIMINAL PUBLIC
SAFETY THREAT THAT WE CAN TAKE
CUSTODY OF.
>> IMMIGRATIONS AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT IS DOUBLING DOWN ON
A POLICY ALLOWING AGENTS TO
ARREST CRIMINAL ALIENS AT THE
COURTHOUSE.
>> THIS POLICY, TO ARREST PEOPLE
IN COURTHOUSES, MAKE SENSE.
>> IN THE PAST, I SEE ARRESTED
CRIMINAL ALIENS IN JAIL.
IT WAS SEAMLESS, SAFE AND
EFFECTIVE.
AND STILL CITIES BANDIT.
IMMIGRANT SUPPORTERS -- >> WE
WILL NOT STAND BY REPRESSIVE,
ENDANGERING FAMILIES.
>> THE NEW DIRECTOR SAYS AGENTS
HAVE NO INTENTION OF SWEEPING
TRAFFICKER CITY COURTS FOR
NONVIOLENT OFFENDERS.
>> THE POLICY PRETTY SPECIFIC.
THE REST OF THE COURTHOUSE,
GOING AFTER TARGETS.
CRIMINAL ALIENS OR TARGETS.
NOT VICTIMS, NOT WITNESSES, NOT
FAMILY MEMBERS.
>> ANOTHER CONCERN, RECENT
HE BLAMES HER RECENT
NINTH CIRCUIT COURT RULING THAT
PROHIBITS DHS FROM HOLDING
CHILDREN FOR MONTHS OR LONGER
UNTIL THEIR ASYLUM HEARING.
THE PRESIDENT WAS A POLICY TO
CHANGE THAT.
>> IT FINALLY ENDS THE HORRIBLE
AND DANGEROUS PRACTICE OF CATCH
AND RELEASE.
>> THE NINTH CIRCUIT RULED
UNACCOMPANIED CHILDREN ARE
ENTITLED TO A BOND HEARING AND
MUST BE PLACED IN THE LEAST
RESTRICTIVE ENVIRONMENT
AVAILABLE.